when i had in my second platoon i had
the the
officer that got fired and i had the
legendary
officer
take over and he was super experienced
he was a prior senior chief
he's a prior senior chief and he didn't
put his he didn't he didn't tell us how
to build pouts he didn't tell us how to
do anything he asked us he put us in
charge he was awesome and as soon as my
lpo said to me hey don't you go to your
job i was like man
that's what
that's what the best leader that i saw
did he did that for us and i'm going to
do that from now on good little lesson
learned yeah no it was so what was that
deployment like so you're you're pretty
early into afghanistan yes what year was
this like 2003 yes
yeah so it was it was it was early but
more importantly again everyone was
focused on iraq so we were
kind of a
like a task unit light so it was mainly
a platoon with some supporting people
some headshed guys
and we weren't really established yet in
uh kind of our our operational sense so
we uh you know we were just trying to
find work and we did a lot of special
reconnaissance a lot of driving around
to afghanistan and non-armored up
humvees and with the doors off it's just
too heavy
and um so we did a lot of those missions
we did a couple of uh direct action
um and it was it was a it was a good
deployment again i learned
a ton
i was with really really good people and
you know we had our issues just like
like everything else but it was a good
learning experience from that but
the main
leadership things and
the oic and i had
a couple of words sometimes and
and it was
again i think that one because he told
me there was a feeling that
you know i kind of got lucky to be in
this
and uh i think he made a comment like
you know guys some guys really earned to
be here
and i was thinking what do you think
i've been doing the last 12 years you
know all this you know when when
i was in my first platoon you're still
riding your huffy bike
up and down the street so
uh yeah i try not to take it personally
and you know it was a lot of growing for
me too because again it was it was kind
of a strange time but
uh you know we came back from uh that
didn't didn't lose anybody and uh and it
was it was a good first deployment to a
combat zone because we got to shake a
lot of stuff out
and we weren't really driving like
you know like we were later or you know
definitely what you guys were doing
later yeah that that's a such a nice
gentle ramp up and i had that too uh
like even even literally when i got to
baghdad in my first deployment
my the the
sea who's a freaking like awesome guy
his wife used to say that me and him
were soul mates but we just always got
along like brothers and but he was
already on the ground and so we showed
up in the night we showed up he's like
hey we're getting
mortared from this area take your
platoon out and go check it out and so
we're like i'm like okay cool and
basically he just kind of made it up
just to get us out there shake out the
whatevers get okay look you're in iraq
now get over it it's time and then you
came back and he's like all right cool
now let's start looking at our first
mission but that's and then that whole
deployment was a nice
ramp up of of learning opportunities to
learn
going back to your point of like when
someone says
you're lucky to be here i was just
talking about this on the academy
uh training leaders
and
one
it's
such a good and we actually just talked
about this on the underground uh
just just saying like yeah
yeah i agree
and
it's so disarming to people when you say
yeah you know i'm 100 lucky to be here
absolutely
and
i wish i had that advice
we all wish we had that advice you know
you're talking to the guy that was
telling the instructor of our
communications course that no it's zulu
time zulu is always zoomed in zulu is
always
19 years old that guy was what 35 he was
a senior chief
uh he was definitely a chief he's a
chief yeah so he's a chief so i'm
telling a chief hey listen chief let me
tell you how it is bro jocko's got a
word to put out son
so yeah we all we all wish we could go
back and maybe freaking check some stuff
but that's that's a good one you know
like hey when somebody tells you
something
and well you nikki it's like okay yeah
absolutely it's disarming it's a way to
understand what their perspective is
it's a good move it's a hard one to
learn it is